welcome back to Hannity i'm jason
chaffetz filling in for sean in this
hannity special socialism rising after
the president took a hard-line stance at
the trump kim summit in on thursday he
called on sean hannity at the post
summit press conference sean reminded
everyone about a Reaganesque lesson of
the Cold War and asked the president a
timely question about his summit with
kim jeong-hoon let's watch mr. president
if you could elaborate a little bit more
we have some history President Reagan
walked away in Reykjavik a lot of
condemnation at the time and it ended up
working out very well in the end for the
United States was this mostly your
decision or and what would message who
you want to send chairman Kim as he's
listening to this press conference about
the future and your relationship well
sure I don't want to say it was my
decision because what purpose is that I
want to keep the relationship and we
will keep the relationship we'll see
what happens over the next period of
time but as you know we got our hostages
back there's no more testing and one of
the things importantly that chairman Kim
promised me last night is regardless
he's not going to do testing of rockets
and nuclear not going to do testing so
you know I trust him and I take him at
his word I hope that's true but in the
meantime we'll be talking Mike will be
speaking with his people he's also
developed a very good relationship with
the people really the people
representing North Korea I haven't
spoken to Prime Minister Abbey yet I
haven't spoken to president moon South
Korea but we will and we'll tell them
it's a process that it's moving along
but we just felt it wasn't appropriate
to sign an agreement today we could have
I just felt it wasn't very appropriate
thank you for watching tonight thanks to
Sean Hannity for letting me guest host
tonight if you enjoyed tonight's show
please feel free to pick up my new book
the deep state how an army of
bureaucrats protected Barack Obama is
working to destroy the Trump agenda